this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday the 12th of [__] may a
beautiful day to be alive the joint is
brought to you by cbd lion
the best listen
i live on this stuff i drink this stuff
whether it's this tape
the gummies the cream
the hemp
the capsules the kinesiology tape listen
cbd line has it down so i advise you to
go to cbdline.com right now and read the
third party lab results see what they
have to ask for and see how cbd lion can
help you go to cbdline.com right now
pressing code joey and get 20
off your first order cbd lion the best
the goods
the joint is also brought to you by like
the welcome green chef is here to help
you eat and feel better every week green
chef sends you new recipes you get over
30 meal choices every week and you can
switch plans easily
always find a healthy and tasty meal
they got options for every lifestyle
keto paleo vegan vegetarian
mediterranean and gluten free let me
tell you something they sent me some
shrimp fried diablo
that was smoking and i'll tell you what
else they got you ready for this one a
ground pork egg roll bowl
does that sound yummy how about the surf
and turf with sun-dried tomatoes listen
green chef is usda
certified organic company that makes it
easy and affordable to eat well you can
get hand-picked organic veggies so you
can feel great about what you're eating
and how it got to your table and a green
chef shows up right at your door with
everything you need if you're busy like
me and you need to eat healthy green
chef
fits perfectly into your lifestyle go to
greenchef.com
joey130 and use code joey130
to get 130 off plus free shipping who
takes care of you like that uncle joey
that's green chef dot com
slash joey130 use promo code joey130
because i'm gonna save you 130.
green chef the number one meal kit for
eating well let's get this party started
it's a beautiful wednesday tarzans
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here wednesday
the 11th of [__] may where is
this month going i don't give a [__]
the cold weather's gone that's all i
give a [__] about i ain't got nothing
against the cold weather but this
[__] neighborhood around here you
need a hooded sweatshirt at night to go
anywhere and if i go over the tenant
road by the [__] softball field over
there that softball field in the words
of jim florentine that [__] is
haunted jack and not with ghost with
cold air that cold [__] ghost that
you it could be a dog i went there six
weeks ago
now i'm lying to you guys maybe four
weeks ago on a sunday
it was sunny all [__] day do you know
when i got to the field i sat there
the sun was [__] shining on tenant
but it was hailing on me
what the [__] that's haunted right there
last night beautiful all [__] day i
go over there for practice [__]
cold as [__] the sun disappears when
you're but even if the sun's out i don't
know what the [__] it is with that field
it's got like a suction on the bottom
like they used to be a town in jersey
called midgetville i don't know please
82 up north by [__] engelwood clips
up there my friends found it there's
like a little town it's just a bunch of
little small people
and you go we go we get [__] up at
night take a head ass and go to [__]
midgetville and drive around then on the
way back we'd stop at dracula's castle
up there and then go with cliffs and
look for dracula you got to be there you
know what i'm saying you got to be a
[__] at that time i was like 16.
but uh what the [__] we thought oh
so
yeah midgetville so i i don't [__]
know where these places are anymore i
don't even know what they exist but i
will tell you something
and this is very weird that i i think
i've discussed this already but there
was also when i was in 82 81
if somebody wants to tell me where it is
but i'll let you know right now
there used to be a hill in northern new
jersey
where if you put your car on neutral
it will either pull you up or pull you
down i don't
i think it was pull you up there's a
city
a street in northern new jersey
somewhere
if somebody remembers it twitter me
patreon me whatever the [__] you do
you park your car you drive up to the
thing put your car in neutral and the
thing would pull you the [__] up so help
me god i was in the [__] car i know i
was 180 at the time but it pulled me and
three other gorillas up and then you go
right down the hill it's you got to see
it to believe it these are the [__]
things you know everybody says the seven
mysteries of the world you don't need to
go there this is a mystery right there
it's like the smell on the turnpike when
you're driving on the 14 when you hit
exit 14 in jersey it smells like cancer
a dead body and 10 dead [__] puerto
ricans put together
trust me you could [__] you could bring
scientists from the world don't ever
find what that odor is that's the
seventh wonder of the world the odor on
the jersey [__] turnpike you
understand me everything i'm used to it
now like people
you know they just found the [__]
grammar school or high school in jersey
i know you [__] i know mike saw
this
they have over a hundred cases of cancer
you people gonna hear about this pretty
soon
some [__] grace middle school
it's up northern new jersey right now as
we speak the kids are [__] home
they're going to other schools because
since 19 something there have been a
hundred brain tumors and different types
of cancer that people who graduated from
that [__] school
this only happens in jersey jack because
god knows what the [__] they bury down
there god [__] knows if these [__]
savages bury it anything not to save a
[__] buck the other day i went
somewhere i saw asbestos in jersey i saw
asbestos at like a [__] hardware
store like the the ceiling was down like
one of those things fell and the
asbestos is just hanging there and
people under there smoking so i'm like
what the [__]
but then again you're in jersey the
seventh wonder of the world don't get me
wrong i love living here i love the
odors
you know you get used to all that [__]
on this earth i remember one time
we stayed in the city and we had to do a
ufc
somewhere like in philly or something we
were doing a show so then rogan goes
let's just go to philly and we got on
route 3 and i showed him my grammar
school and if you keep going i'll never
forget this there was like into sea
caucus we got stuck in traffic and there
was like a puddle
and a thing and it had algae growing and
i go
joe and ari were in the car i go you see
that puddle that's cancer
that's what that is over the years
they've just dumped and dumped and
dumped listen
we could talk about this for [__]
hours but
guys if you it's going to become a
national story soon
it hasn't caught wind yet i mean they
talk about it every night on the news
here locally about the school the tumors
but that's
[__] insane
anyway who gives a [__] about dumas it
was a great weekend it was a great week
we gave you guys a couple in-house
guests i'm really happy
that covert is gone and now i can see
the light a little bit
with some guest people are scared i got
some other guests coming in studio i got
some great zooms we're becoming like a
hybrid podcast it's either solo
zoom or a [__] in-house guest and in
time we'll spread this out a little more
and get this more feasible
i you know
every week i look at the [__] online
somebody sent me uh my realtor sent me
something to look for like an office
the lady who sold me the house is always
like sending me [__] every week
that's nothing it's
you know a friend of mine suggested he
was thinking of moving into the area
and i just said you know what i'll take
a look i'm not good at looking for
apartments and all that stuff
but i went on that dog
they're charging all the doll for rents
i mean the money situation is getting
wild it's funny saturday night
i'm watching you know i
i bet oliveira after the [__] thing i
didn't you know you're not going to make
any money on oliveira it's just to tell
people you bet olivera the money was on
gagey
and uh
i bet oliveira and i you know i i didn't
know what he was going to do gaijin has
been talking a big game for a while now
you know beside that gagey
can hit hard in a [__] truck
you know once he starts going he starts
going the thing about i'm a fan of gages
but
kg either beats the living [__] out of
you or he just looks like a bus hit him
like after a fight because he puts
everything in there you know
that was one of the most exciting fights
i've [__] seen in years i didn't even
care if i lost i listen when i watch
those fights
i bet ten dollars sometimes just to
watch the fight to cheer for somebody
last week i started betting totals like
i bet the total on the rose
the most boring fight in the [__]
world i got no disrespect for those two
girls
at all their coaches would tell them to
fight a strategic fight to wait for the
booze to be patient and
everybody was crucifying them listen it
happens not all fights could be [__]
uh you know
super unknown
but the charles de la vera fight was
[__] tremendous and i got on twitter
and i'm like [__]
you know charles oliver just give him
back the belt see they they did that
thing with the half a half a [__]
pound
that kid's as straight as a [__]
island then they made them test the
scale again
then people started [__] call
fighters started calling them up going
charles what the [__] that scale is
defective and dana
you guys
see when he does these little moves like
that what he's trying to do he's trying
to make [__] room for our boy but i
gotta tell you something
after those fights saturday night i'm a
kind of fan i respect his power i
respect what he's done in the game
but guys i don't see him coming back
against those three
either chandler either oliveira
or gay g for that matter i mean i don't
know what's going on with tony uh
my
you know my [__] the best to him i
see oliveira put out his hand to help
him train kaku's got a lot of talent
somewhere in there
sometimes in your career sometimes in
life dog you go blink
you can't be [__] great every day you
can't be superman every day once you
realize that don't make your life a lot
[__] easier you can't be superman
every day
so i hope he uh gets it together but the
interesting thing happened
i put oliver give him back the [__]
belt
and then i put something on there about
i go clean him again because every
[__] fight
every time there's a [__] fight i
gotta wake up on sunday
to to to conor mcgregor [__] laying
into fighters who actually fought the
night before
who actually fought the night before
guys listen i took a little hiatus from
what i love and what i do
but at the same [__] time i'm not
sitting every sunday i don't wake up and
go did you guys go to segura's show did
he say the same jokes did you guys see
rogan well yeah i'm not [__] cheering
him away he's like cheering him away
they just like he [__] opened up on
gagey sunday like gage he needs that
that he got beat up so i just put poor
mcgregor's at home shadow boxing
you know and i just put it out and the
next morning i wake up people like conor
mcgregor [__] replied to you all this
[__] people he's mad at he's not mad at
me it's a [__] yeah he replied of a
car going on to a speedboat you know
and i loved it
i must have got [__] 200 more
followers
just from conor mcgregor tweeting your
back i mean it's
it's insane you know
and it's so funny you get the cliche
things you know from some of his lovers
like he's at home with a lot of money
you know guys
i'm really happy
that there's still people that think
this way
guys i know
10 depressed millionaires
i know 10 depressed millionaires in real
life i know 10 millionaires right now
that are losing
their [__] minds
i can say who they are d and you can
just
go on instagram and look for yourself
but money does not buy you happiness
you know
i cheer for my guys that are on the road
i speak to hari every week i talk to
bert
i talked to tom i talked to my friends i
talked to eric roach i talked to the
agostino i called him up to congratulate
him on the netflix it's a joke festival
i try to bring up these guys i'm not i
don't call people just to blow smoke on
their ass if i like you and i think
you're doing something i [__] try to
bring you up you know
and that's that's my world for it i got
nothing against connor you know
i know it must be tough for him
to watch these guys flourish and grow
you know he's at home lifting weights
but he's not on the mat
or maybe he's hitting pads i don't know
he's got to be doing something because
he's fighting in july he's got to pick
an opponent something's got to go down
but i didn't mean
meaning no disrespect but it got to let
me know
about how people feel out there
where it comes to like you guys and
listen
don't feel bad i was the same thing i
always thought that
money
bought you everything like i in our
minds we are built as americans i think
as americans i know for sure but as
americans we are raised to believe
that money will give us all these
[__] things you know i can't i feel
so bad for women right now
women are in a tough situation because
it was like i was telling a friend of
mine the other day we were talking about
phones kids phones and he's like how do
you control
mercy's phone use and i go there ain't
no [__] phone
i go she gets a play phone on the
weekends to play games on
i don't download and listen we have a
game guy in la any game she wants my
wife will call the guy and the guy goes
she can't download that it's not good so
we got a lead on all that [__]
i a couple months ago i went to dinner
and i noticed that my wife my daughter
didn't lift her head up one time and i
told my wife when we got home tomorrow
morning the phone gets yanked no more
restaurants none of that [__]
because you really gotta watch
gotta watch all that [__] you know
but like i feel my buddy said to me i
had to give my daughter a phone because
she's got friends
and her friends got phone and then the
kid feels bad it's like so i go oh it's
like us growing up with bad sneakers
like when i was growing up if you were
[__] shoprite sneakers you got rocks
thrown at you
you
every day you see two kids running a
little [__] kid and a little kid with
cheap sneakers because people are
throwing rocks at them and [__] you know
what i'm saying it's a [__] nightmare
it's a nightmare when i was growing up
if you didn't have the right shoes oh
boy would they lay into you
if your sneakers slip and slide take
them back to panty pride that type of
[__] like kids will say that she in
class i think one time my mom got me
like wrong kids like i asked her for pro
kids and this is [__] second grade in
new york city
1960 [__] nine my mom got me kids
instead of pro kids oh my god you
thought i'd kill somebody how much they
tortured me they chased me home they
threw things at me you had to wear pro
kids or [__] chuck taylors that was
it if you don't have those two
you got tormented you wouldn't even wear
sneakers because you knew you just wore
combat boots because you knew they're
going to talk there were kids there were
so many kids that were [__] tap
dancing she was a gym because they got
tortured you can't no no no no and don't
don't even think of wearing colored
socks
they got to be white dog don't come in
here
no don't come in here with your black
socks those are the that's a re that's
like if you go to the cop like if the
cop says to you why'd you mug them he
had black socks on i get it i would have
mugged them too you know and i grew up
in the 70s if you have black socks on
with sneakers they take it to the side
let's have a talk are you [__] or
what
oh my god like the ones our dads used to
wear i used to go to my friend's house
and the dads would have boxer shorts to
the [__] leg above the knee and then
the sock an inch under it like where the
[__] are you going with that and then
now i know they're like arthritis socks
or blood pressure socks i didn't [__]
know back then that you know i'm like
why does he have your father why's he
got socks to his knees i don't know he's
your thought leave him alone
but it's so weird how
people really think that money buys you
[__] happiness like it really does
and it helps out
i'm not gonna tell you it doesn't help
out but if you think you're gonna feel
better
like if you lost a mom do you think you
feel better if you bought a 50 000 car
see do you see what i'm saying here
nothing replaces that you think if your
child
gets hurt or something like that you
think by going and buying a gold
bracelet it's going to make it better
you know the only thing i like about
money is one [__] thing if you're a
woman you got two choices in life you
could suck dick in a one bedroom
apartment you could suck dick in a
mansion
that's up to you i heard that years ago
i don't even know why i'm saying it but
it [__] made sense to me back then
but
you think about it guys all these guys
you see with money elon musk all these
guys
i hope you don't think that they wake up
in the morning and they got [__]
they're walking on clouds they got
shitty lives just like us guys
and sometimes those lives are shittier
because they can't come out and really
say what's going on with them what if
elon musk got a one-inch dick
why have 44 million dollars if you got a
one-inch deck you ever think about that
so don't ever wake up in the morning
thinking oh he's got it better than me
look at women women every woman in
america if you're young has been
influenced by the kardashians in some
way more importantly kim
you know she's got the world by the ball
she dates music artists she hangs out
with this guy that guy the other guy
it's pretty [__] impressive if you're
a young girl you want to grow up to be
like [__] kim so what do you do have
a [__] sex tape did you see what
happened last week the sex tape was a
[__] fix the mom orchestrated it i
mean come on like i told you guys a long
time ago the california family bond is
non-existent it's just [__]
it's just a family to have a family when
your own mom pimps you out that's how
she became a star with a [__] porno
tape but anyway it's not here or there
we're talking about the happiness money
brings you and
even them i mean even kim kardashian
she's a [__] gazillionaire
she's had about four weddings already
four marriages already where's the
happiness now she's on to another guy
how long will that last he's another
hollywood guy i got nothing against pete
but think about it
happiness is having a husband a loving
husband who loves you no matter what
is having a great [__] wife that's
happiness happiness isn't [__] but
money can't buy you that but we
as americans always go well if i had
[__] money this would be different
guys i know
200 [__] millionaires and 100 of them
don't know what to do
how did they become millionaires who
knows families
some of them [__] worked who the [__]
knows
but you know you see them and
it's not the answers to their [__]
problems they think it is
for you listen
joey why did you rob the guy
because he had two kilos of coke it was
going to give me the head bump i've been
waiting for i was 27 years old 26 years
old whatever the [__] i was and i needed
a little bump to get ahead now i always
knew that even with the bump i would
snort the bump you know what i'm saying
like if mike came to me tomorrow he's
like joey i'm 22. i'm in a [__] pinch
i'm going to get out of my mother's
house blah blah blah if i give him 15
and he then he goes and snorts it i you
know i'm saying i can't help him so i
was in the same boat i was always
looking
you know i always thought that having a
tester rosa would get you women and
having all
guys
it doesn't do [__] for you and i saw it
firsthand in l.a i went to houses that
would blow you the [__] out of the water
and these guys did not know what to do
with it in fact it makes it worse it
makes it worse and i tell you who i was
around for a long time
and he showed me
that money didn't buy happiness and his
name was ralphie may
ralphie made bumped into money got
rested so
that [__] went off the rails in
a great way i mean the great i was
thinking about this the other day i
remember when he first hit
like he went on the road for like six
weeks i didn't see him
and he would call me and tell me stories
about how much they were paying them and
how much he was laughing their faces and
[__] because these guys wouldn't pay him
they didn't respect them as a fat [__]
you know for ralphie he was always
embarrassed of being from arkansas
like he grew up dirt poor people grew up
dirt poor
they grew up with a [__]
chip on their back people grow up dirt
poor i'm talking about dirt poor
they grow up with a chip in their back
you can't take that memory away from
that
that memory burns in your [__] soul
it burns
trust me i have other memories that burn
in my soul but being poor i know people
have been poor and when you talk to them
like my uncle my mom they were poor in
cuba when my mom used to tell me stories
i didn't believe them my uncle confirmed
them they were poor
there were nine [__] kids in a little
apartment with one in the house in the
living room there weren't even enough
blankets for all them they would have to
share [__] blankets at night and
every night they didn't have air
conditioning i had to sleep with the
window open so carrying bugs would land
on them chicarian bugs the ones that
make the noises i'm not saying it right
you know i'm not a [__] scientist
some cicadas something was landing on
them making noises it was horrible
my uncle you said my uncle for an hour
eat lunch with him and he'll tell you
stories of poverty
that you can't [__] believe people
went through it but
when he told me all that it explained my
mother's spending
it explained my mother's way of life and
explained to me why she was like that
she never wanted to be in that position
ever again
once you're poor and you get out those
[__]
become counterfeiters they start
printing money they do they really do
start printing [__] money
because they don't ever want to be in
that position again and ralphie was one
of those guys but ralphie also dragged
drug in
a certain sadness
you know he was he didn't grow up only
poor
he grew up [__] fat
so they were blowing him up because he
was
fat
and because he was poor i mean ralphie
was dirt [__] poor
and guys when he got an envelope he went
off
the [__] rails i loved it because i
like to see people happy like that
but then as the years progressed i could
tell
when he would come get me on mondays
when he would come back
we would talk man we would talk the way
to real people talk not a comic ralphie
it was just him telling me about
what was happening out there and
the sadnesses he had and even after all
that money yes it was a band-aid for
about two years
and helped him forget it passed for
about two years but guess what that past
is always with you when i look in the
mirror when i go to the bathroom and
when i take a piss i look in the mirror
i go boy you're getting uglier
but i also see that there's a past there
we know it and it pops up from time to
time and it bothers you it aggravates
you you know whatever the [__] it does
you know it it motivates you for me it
motivates me
you know
a friend of mine is going through a
tough patch
he's getting a lot of anxiety the way i
was getting it so he reached out you
know
and i had to break things down for him
and what like he goes when you started
reaching
were you going to be a star and i go
no
i was very ashamed that i had done time
i still am that's why i always make
jokes about it because that's like the
other day when i go it's my mother's
anniversary in hell and some people gave
me [__] for that listen when it comes to
painful things you always have to throw
some joke in there to [__] really you
know to relieve the pain it's like when
you get whip with a belt
it doesn't hurt you when you
hit with a belt it hurts you a couple
minutes later when it starts to swell up
if you put the cream on it real [__]
quick it doesn't start to swell up
that's what we try to do you know
but
i saw ralphie how sad he was at the end
like i always tell people
dog ralphie at the end died of a broken
heart
and all the money in the world couldn't
mend that
so
to the people who were saying you know
it was like two or three people that
said at least he drove to the game
tonight he drove to the whatever all the
money he has
if you went to mcgregor and took the
whiskey away angle let me talk to you
man to man who would you rather have the
hundred million
would you rather be in that car tonight
with michael chandler and [__]
aloe vera doing your thing and smacking
[__] you'd be surprised to what he
[__] say to you
if he was really being heartfelt and
honest and everybody wants to be in the
big [__] arena nobody wants to be
down for me
i wanted to get the [__] out of the
light i didn't give a [__] my wife asked
me was you going through this and i go
not at all
i want to dissipate from that you know i
want to move away from that but that
doesn't give me the right
to wake up on sunday mornings and go who
wants to see [__] george perez last
night in indiana you got beat he's a bad
performance i never did that i never did
that at all i wouldn't even think of
doing that if anything i call these
these guys hey listen when you're a
comic you're [__] up like the other
talks i used to have with ralphie on
saturday mornings
that's why every saturday morning about
10 30 i was looking when i look at the
phone i think about ralphie every
saturday
every saturday ralphie pops back into my
life as a reminder
that that was our little personal time
he'd probably go to bed at two or three
he'd probably eat like two boxes of
those jalapeno pop as he liked
he would go to bed at two or three and
when he first got up at seven the fart
or the [__] p
after he finished he called me asked me
how i was doing what my struggles were
and we just chitchat but dog and none of
those struggles
was
did he say after this weekend i pick up
50 000
i'm not going to be depressed about this
anymore not at all
he still had the daily everyday
struggles and it was because of ralphie
by watching ralphie
i slowed down my pace for the quest of
being greedy and all that [__]
in l.a because i didn't want all that
stuff to get in my way and to kill me
there's no listen
there's no reason to lose your life like
that he was heavy he wasn't healthy and
they put him out there and for years i
kept sending them down going ralphie but
that eaten that's pain guys when you
keep eating like that that's pain how do
i know because i was there i was [__]
there
in 2007 when i got clean then a year
later when i went to weight watchers i
didn't do all that [__] because i wanted
to be johnny bananas i did that [__]
because the pain was gone the pain i had
endured all those years earlier
had been [__] gone so it was tough
it the pain
had how do you say lessened what's
dissipated that's the word i'm looking
for thank god i got my man mike here
because i usually forget my man
chris camozzi he was a [__] savage i
love this guy always putting out [__]
self-defense videos call me a few weeks
ago and he goes joey i want to send you
something let me know what you think
guys everybody sends me something and
then i let them know what i think and
then i got to be embarrassed
dog you sent me this fit for life i'm
going to give you a couple of take home
the [__]
orange cream
holy [__]
zero [__] calories bcaas
protein
this is the [__] future i'm he's not
my sponsor i'm just trying to tell you
what's a good [__] product if you see
it somewhere give it a try i think he
sent me lemon lime and the orange cream
i had not tried the lemon lime but i've
had about six of these [__]
orange cream
and i tell you what
really got me going on this today was
i've been doing podcasts how long
felicia ten years right
yeah
after every podcast some somebody has
something to say to you
do they agree with you maybe they
disagree with you whatever
you know
you get a couple per podcast
but in all my 10 years of podcasting
i never got as many emails as i did in
all the [__] forums
from [__] uh
facebook to twitter
a couple people hotmailed me a couple
people messenged me it was overwhelming
about the [__] talk we had about
finances
with me and lee that day
guys it was [__] overwhelming
like
use all right if i get 10 emails on the
subject joey we like that don't mix it
in with something else like are you
really going to the
lat factory or you're going to be you
know it's always something no
these were people going dog
we're happy you [__] talked about
that i've been banging my head off the
wall i can't sleep and that's why i told
people thinking about all that [__]
destroys you
destroys you i know it destroyed me when
i was younger when i was a lot of people
don't remember and i've said this for
years is that [__] i had ulcers when
i was 20.
and those ulcers were not caused from
pain
those ulcers were caused about my future
i was one of those jerk-offs okay you
know
everybody has a different [__] uh
weakness i was one of those guys i had
nothing going to [__] on but i always
thought about my future and i i remember
the specific point what happened was i
gave up a job
making 140 a day as a bookmaker 140 plus
that's where the job started some days
i'd take 220 home and tip some days i
took 180 but it was always 140 seven
days a week listen even in these times
that's not a bad [__] job for a 20
year old man a kid a [__] [__] so i
would meet them and see caucus at the
howard johnson's because they used to
have salt and water taffy
we get two eggs bacon the whole [__]
works and then me and the guys would get
some salt water tap we'd get in the
[__] route three
drive to uh 118th street and third
avenue
we'd open up our little [__] bodega
and right there we'd start slinging
[__] numbers people would come in and
and then i have to go to different
locations to pick up money blah blah
blah i had a great job guys and when i
got out of work i was right there i had
to walk three blocks over here to pick
up a g-ball powder and i had to walk two
blocks over there to get a [__] 20
bag of thai weed i was in my [__]
glory but i knew that if you know
anything about me or if i know anything
about you [__] you're not gonna
look for another job when you have those
type of jobs and pretty soon you're
gonna be there five years pretty soon
you're gonna be there ten years and then
when there's when you're there ten years
when you're 31 years old there's going
to be a [__] raid and now you're
going to have bookmaking on your [__]
uh
resume which is a misdemeanor in new
york no big [__] deal
and
but now you're going to go to ralph's or
you're going to go to costco or you're
going to go to shoprite or you're going
to go to any corporation apply for a job
and they're going to go where
have you been for the last 10 years so
tell me about your job what are you
going to say i've been marketing numbers
what are you going to say
so i knew that wasn't going to work for
me i thank god at that age i had figured
that the [__] out that someday i'm 31
that's not gonna happen in 10 years from
now but all that thinking used to make
me bleed out of my [__] let's just
get to that [__] that's how bad my
[__] ulcer was when you have blood
coming out of your ass you're thinking
too [__] much so that's the point i
was that's why i want to let you
youngsters know don't [__] think
do
because when you think about your future
how are you going to buy a house how are
you going to buy a car
how are you going to keep this woman
happy she wants diamonds to and you you
want to keep eating her ass it tastes
like flowers but you know
it cost you 800 a week just to have this
[__] torture chamber around
and you got to [__] function as a man
you don't want to drive a 200 [__]
car everywhere that's good when you're
18 you're delivering [__] you know
whatever the [__] haircuts or whatever
the [__] you're delivering nowadays you
can make a [__] 80 000 a year now
delivering cars you don't need any
[__] skills and i ain't mad at you i
mean listen if this was 40 years ago and
i didn't want to do stand-up i'd be i
was delivering chinese food what the
[__] are we talking about i delivered
chinese food and soaked for years and
the nights i was off from there i would
double the dominoes because they would
give me like 15 a mile
they were open late you dealt with
college kids they gave you a reefer for
whatever but that's not the [__]
point
so i got a [__] hosa when i was 20.
i'll never forget i quit that job and
maybe a year later i'm in snowmass
village and i'm this [__] 60 year old
doctor and he's [__] feeling my
stomach he took x-rays he made me drink
this green [__]
and he goes you got a nelson man you got
to stop thinking and i use what are you
thinking about what the [__] you
thinking about doc i'm 20 i got no high
school diploma i got no high school
college education i got nothing going on
what the [__] am i going to do and he's
like just stop thinking write a plan and
pace it the [__] out
you know the only people ask me like how
do you buy out guys this is my first
house i wasn't eligible to buy a house
they would have thrown me
dawg if they do a background check don't
they want look at the house they would
have said well come here
what are you looking at the house for
you you need a shack chubby you don't
need a [__] house
or you got no credit
but i know that my wife is a very good
saver
and we made a plan
to put away money for the future
and it was a certain amount and then i
realized that
i couldn't do
anything with the other amount she gave
me so i donated that too i go i'm just
living off the [__] flights for a
long time when you uh book a plane
ticket through a comedy club don't
they'll give you like uh i don't know
seven hundred dollars for a plane ticket
500 for a plane ticket
you don't know that i was living off
those 500 miles that asked me do you
want your plane ticket involved in your
cat and your cash and i go no give me
the plane ticket cash and keep you i was
living off that plane ticket that's how
i
paid for gas i went on the road if i got
like 1200 bucks in cash that's how i
lived the month like i don't it's not
that we're going out every night or
anything like that i like to eat good
and stuff like that but i don't want to
be in a restaurant every night i'm not
one of those guys even for my daughter's
communion party i told my wife i do not
want to be in a restaurant at 12 o'clock
in a catering hall we're doing it in the
[__] yard and thank god it was two
weeks ago and it was sunny and the birds
were chirping last weekend we got i
thought i was [__] older i thought it
was noah it rained here so [__] much
i went out that tide to one day it was
three inches in my garbage can i'm like
jesus said [__] the reins in jersey but
the main thing is
just get a plan together
you know listen i was dead serious when
lee was here i saw something
that these companies are coming in and
buying all these houses a hundred
thousand dollars over [__] whatever
just to get them off them they don't
even care what their houses look like
they're buying these houses unseen
so i'm gonna tell you something guys you
got maybe
honestly i mean
i mean i studied economics in college
but i'm not an economist
you guys got about three years to buy a
house
three four years
interest rates are going up you know
unless you got a ton of money they're
not gonna let you buy a house
that's not by coincidence guys that's by
design they don't want you to own
anything
they want all you guys that are coming
up now not to own a [__] thing
but you're gonna dazzle you're gonna
start buying [__] land i don't give a
[__] what you do
there's a piece of property around the
corner there i called the guy two weeks
ago just see what it is like they said
in the sopranos god ain't making any
more land
that's a [__] shitty house by the rec
center i saw the other day for sale by
owner
get four of us and buy it tear that
[__] house down and just it's like a
that's a real investment that's a real
investment i wouldn't mind having a
piece of [__] land that's a real
[__] investment you know get it
surveyed make sure you can build on it
make sure there's not a wild life
reserve
you know so
i mean yeah you got about three or four
years to buy something and you could buy
anything i'm suggesting right now
buy anything you can i don't care what
it even looks like
i don't even care what it looks like
if you're young right now guys i would
be [__] putting money away
is this something that i did
i invested in cocaine i was a [__]
[__]
you guys have a chance to invest and get
yourself out of this [__] listen guys
there was nothing more scary than me
than getting old
there was nothing scary to me
when i knew that
i couldn't use my back anymore to make a
living
i mean if my daughter was starving and
my wife couldn't get a job
i'd have to go out and [__] uh
build a wall or be a laborer for a
concrete company and stuff like that do
you really think i could do that at 59
well
i hope you [__] got confidence in me
because i don't
carrying wheelbarrows and [__] and cat
my buddy's putting roof on around the
corner i went over there sunday and just
tried to climb on the ladder a little
bit i'm like whoa
it's a different [__] world well
guess what guys the last 10 years
i prepared for this but before that
i used to sit there and watch all these
retirement commercials you ever seen
like you know all right do you have
enough to retire and i go what the [__]
are you talking about
and i would just go i hope when i'm
[__] like 55 i just punched a ticket
because this is never gonna happen in my
life thank god it did
thank god i have a good wife that we
decided to put away money then you know
i [__] hated putting money away
i hated it and it was the best advice
given to me guys when i was a kid you
could walk into a bank and start a
christmas club
do you know i read something about a
year ago about a guy in new york
that took all his christmas clubs from
like 15 years put them together and
bought like a property
and he they just i forget the name of
the property i was built on it the guy
was a multi-millionaire when he was 30
years old because he saved all those
christmas clubs i don't even think banks
do christmas clubs
you walk into a [__] bank you go
listen
i want to start a christmas club how
much do you want to put away a week 20.
not a bad christmas club at the end of
the year then they mail you a check on
the 20th you tell them can i get my
check on the 20th you would run that
through a bank
and every year they would get i know i'm
talking about it joey asked me how many
[__] christmas clubs did you do
one because then i took the money out
after i hit 30 bucks for a [__] toy
or something
because i like to spend all my money i
was one of those idiots i didn't stop
till the last penny was gone but then i
go where's the money at but as you get
older and you see how people live in l.a
you know i know people in l.a don't make
that much money but they got four
[__] heavy duty cars
somebody's got to make those [__] car
payments you know so i don't wanna i
don't wanna
the fight club makes a lot of sense you
don't want the things you own to own you
it gets to a point in your life where
you're just going to work
to pay off the boat the car the tv
the mistress the mistresses kid the
drummer from this band you know you have
all this
and right now guys
if you're young 24 25
i mean listen when i was 24 and 25 i
didn't look at anything
but times are changing guys if you
really want to make a stake
in this [__] world in this [__]
life right now early
because by the time you're 40 like me
like when i woke up out of my cocaine
coma
at least i woke up out of that comb and
caught the last 10 years of a life and i
tried to salvage something i really did
try to salvage something that's what i
did and i did okay
but you know what that's not good enough
anymore
that's not good enough anymore guys you
can't live the way i did it's a
different time in this world you know
mike's got to be putting money away for
his children mike works [__] weddings
on saturday i know that money is not to
[__] go to strip clubs
you know it's for weddings and [__]
this and that
you know you always spend michael tell
you where are we spending two kids
two kids
listen there ain't enough money in the
world when you got two kids
okay there ain't enough money in the
[__] world so
having a family now owning a home doing
all these things is a different
[__] world so if you're in college
right now if you're 22
listen
if i met you 20 years ago and you were
22 and you go uncle joey what's the best
advice i'd give you i'd be like tom
hanks don't get the clap
what does that mean sling dig get a job
get high do whatever the [__] you want i
wouldn't give you that advice anymore
i give you the advice to
approach everything with caution and
get two jobs
whatever
until you get your [__] hustle going
whatever it could be house painting
your own thing you know what i'm saying
like that second job you have at night
from five to eight that money's log
banking that's all going into the bank
to help you get your [__] dream going
whatever that [__] dream may be so
you sit down you go to yourself how much
is it going to cost me to get this
[__] thing started off the ground
without a 38 000 headquarters you know
what i'm saying let's be honest here
don't come to me and say joey we're
looking for investors me and my friends
want to put together a spanish
grateful dead band
we need about 30 000 to record the first
album we really wanted to have a sound
so we wanted to be in the bahamas really
so you're looking for donations to send
you to the [__] bahamas let's do this
why don't we cut the bahamas out and we
shoot in [__] newark new jersey and
i'll get a couple bahamians to come over
and cook and [__] play bongos and you
could feel that vibe i'll get them in
for you know at 25 an hour i'll get them
in for two hours a day just to help you
with that vibe but why are you figuring
out
20 000 into recording an album in the
studio on an island when you're putting
the gofundme page together you're
looking for [__] investors that's my
i raised my hand right there so if
you're looking to start a business and
you're telling me well joe we need a
[__] corporate office i need 80 000
square feet here listen take that dream
get a needle and pop it like my stomach
like mitzy sure used to pop my stomach
it's never gonna pan out for you let's
start small here
let's start small here when you see this
podcast studio when i came here it was
covered
it was covered people were [__] dying
don't touch me everybody was walking
around like a [__] vampire i really
wanted to go to asbury park at that time
when i got here john around the corner
had a little office in ashbury park on
the second floor i'm like what am i
going to get an office for ain't nobody
going to come to asbury park ain't
nobody going to [__] come to it right
then and now so what did you want me to
do [__] just go out and rent the hugh
studio and lights and
three staff members yeah that's great
but i'm an econ major [__] you know
what i'm saying the numbers don't add up
what's coming in is less than what's
going on so let's figure it to go in
unless that's going the [__] out so we
started here a couple more guests in
here covert clears up for the summer you
know i'm going to be looking for even if
i turn that [__] garage into a
[__] studio with air conditioner i
want something a little bigger and [__]
like that but that's what i'm talking
about
you know start small
make a website
make a website learn about what the [__]
you're doing in your business i mean
listen i'm not an investor i would love
to tell you you know invest in amazon
you know buy netflix i i don't know
anything i know what you want me to do
what i know
i know hard work
i don't put your money away i know
making goals
i mean figuring out the [__] out
you know when i was in debt all those
years you don't you know when i i always
crack this joke but it's a true story
when i was doing cocaine i'd become a
mathematician i don't know what it was
about cocaine towards the end
i would sit there and write [__]
pages
of math like how long is it going to get
to me if i make 200 a week how long
would it get me to get out of this debt
like i was one of those idiots
what if i paid 400 a week even though i
knew i couldn't pay 400 a week in my
head but i i opened up my mind to that
so there were certain weeks when yeah
joey snorted coke with three hands but
joey also had to make those payments if
you look at my credit today guys i
should have gone belly up in 93
but i disappeared
i went and got a pager the credit call
stopped nobody was looking for me
and it took about eight or nine years of
me not i had one credit card if i spent
a dollar i have to pay 250 on it
you know what i'm saying like it would
if i say if dog if i bought
if i took my wife to a restaurant spent
250 if my limit was 500 i'd get a call
in three weeks that my limit was 500
because my thing would double that high
on interest
because i had no credit don't [__] your
credit up
yeah you can salvage it but you got to
live like a month for 11 years and when
you go to a hotel you got no credit card
to check in so you gotta check in with a
[__] payable visa card from costco
they gotta load up no
don't [__] up your credit and those
[__] school loans
[__] let me tell you something
i beat them for 26 26.25 i thought i
beat those [__] for 26.25 the
first time i put 2000 in my bank account
that [__] went right to washington dc
and they contacted me immediately uncle
joey's 26 25 plus interest i had to hire
an attorney
to knock the points off
because it had been a loan from 1990
yeah guys the federal government don't
go away they're like the irs how do you
think all these [__] end up in
jail they go to those comic cons and
they take those dollar bills for those
autographs and there's a [__]
over there with sunglasses that you
think is blind he's watching he's like
there's mike signing autographs at 10
apiece there goes one two two weeks
later you're at home jumping up and down
i'm going to comic-con hawaii bling it's
the government and we saw you in
comic-con minneapolis popularly 3 000.
where's our [__] money you did 15 of
those last year so we're just gonna
assume you made 3 000 on those
[__] so fan over that 45 grand
and you're like whoa
dog pay your [__] bills
so you don't have to live like a [__]
mutt like i did for 10 years under the
radar with a pager
i don't know about the taxes they take
time to catch up with you but
they will i'm only kidding you pay your
[__] taxes [__] but let me
tell you something again this is
something that happened to me that i did
not know
why didn't i know that because for life
everybody scares the [__] out of you
i think this life i knew for me
everybody all my life tried to scare the
[__] out of me
and it's not until you [__] go you
know what i'm not scared no more and
then you're like
why'd this [__] scare me for
this wasn't [__]
[__] have been scaring me
all my [__] life what are we talking
about taxes about taxes when i started
commenting i got divorced in 91.
i got a [__] what do you call those
w-9s i got a w-9 for a lot of money
and i was and i was sitting in front of
the i was sitting in front of the tax
paperwork
and i'm like
this just came in the mail
if i just send this in
i got to check for about 800.
but if i send this in with the check
i'm gonna owe my life i don't have
[__] eight nine thousand dollars
so i took the sheet of paper and i
ripped it up
and i threw it away and i sent the taxes
and guess what they actually sent me my
little 800.
and i cashed the dog fast and the rap
dog
i basically took it out of the mailman's
hand and ran to that [__] banking
bowl and i cashed it
because i thought they were going to get
me on that 60 g's 70 g's
i just said [__] and guys let me tell
you something my credit went sour it
broke my heart i i think i cried for a
month straight i was disgusted
people are giving me credit and i had
spit in their face i i felt [__]
horrible
so i would send 40s and 60s but you're
never going to catch up
you're never going to get it you know
it's like and vogue you're never going
to get it you're never going to [__]
catch up
and you're petrified and i just didn't
pay [__] so guys i stopped paying
taxes from 1990
i didn't pay a dime i just hit on the
ground until
2001.
i met terry in 2000 and terry asked me
if i was doing taxes like we were
together about nine months on my taxes
[__] that and she's like
dog her head almost blew up she's like
joey you gotta do your taxes i'm like
i'm not doing [__]
and the first year i didn't do
and she was a little upset
and then like 2001
she's like joe you gotta take care
because i owed the government i heard
child support i was a [__] mess
and terry's like i just want you to
narrow this life down i just want you to
narrow it down so we know where we're at
i go i don't want to know where i'm at
i'm not going to be able to [__] pay
this and we went at it for a couple
[__] days and finally one day i
called the irs and i said i'd like to
set up an appointment
guys i gotta taste them
i took the best shower i ever took
before i went to the irs meeting i
shaved my [__] i loofed it
because i didn't think i was gonna come
back but i got no reason to lie to you
guys i thought they were luring me in
like yeah we'd love to see you come on
down and talk about your tax problems
i'm like i'm gonna go down there and
they're gonna [__] just keep me
i got high i put [__] a joint in my
underwear i mean i was petrified
i walked down there bro they do
everything but rub your [__] feet at
the irs office
dog they just want you to go down and
take care of it please guys
if you owe the irs
listen they're not going away it's not
like joe the bookie he's not going to
jail it's not like your uncle pete he's
a [__] cancer victim this these
[__] these [__] do not go
away
go down there
talk to them go up there with an empty
with an empty [__] open up with an
open heart would have been an empty
heart
go up there with empty pockets and an
open heart and just tell them your
situation when that woman looked at me
and said it's going to be 150 a month
for three years
and i looked around that room i'm like
this has to be like a [__]
camera like this is how
guys i didn't pay taxes for 10 [__]
years
she looked me in the face and she goes
can you pay 150 a month for three months
with that
for three years she goes would that put
you out too much and i go
listen ten dollars a month to put me out
i like snorting you know what i'm saying
but if it means not going to jail in 20
years and not having any beefs with you
because when they come looking for you
guys
they come
they come pretty soon you go to your
bank account you take your girlfriend
out to dinner you speak in italian and
[__] oh yes
and also you put that atm down that way
it comes back
came up [__] empty you're like it's
impossible
you know i just put two thousand dollars
in there call the bank you got two
hundred two dollars in that bank account
that's what they did take it out they
took it from me
they took it from philippe spa they
broke they don't [__] around so when
that lady looked at me and she goes will
150 a month work for you mr diaz and i
was like
it'll have to work
three years
i looked at my way let's do it we signed
the paperwork i didn't miss a [__]
payment
i am not going to jail for the irs i'm
not doing it so please i know and you
probably think you own thousands listen
i didn't pay taxes for 10 and i had two
big years in the sports betting industry
and the roofing industry
so they only they only go back seven
they only go back seven so you even if
you didn't pay taxes 15 years they only
go back seven guys they go in those
years so don't lie to them about those
last seven years don't tell me you
didn't make any money
and i'll tell you man it took the
[__] it opened me up like you you
think about things that you do that make
you successful or that put you on the
right path i got to tell you something
paying your bills
put you on the right path
there was two payments that were hanging
on my head the irs
and child support i didn't know a lot in
child support
but towards the end i was getting
charged they wanted fourteen thousand
dollars they kept coming at me saying
we want fourteen thousand dollars
fourteen thousand dollars for and i'm
like
i gave you a lot of money my wife went
and took all the money orders and we
added up and we're like we owe you 14
and then i actually called la and i like
look ready for this story guys i called
ballet and that was like
come on down give us 60.
the colorado bill
had became the
california bill
california so scumbags
they took
a fourteen hundred dollar loan
and built it at sixty 000 they said i
owed that much
the next morning my wife got it we were
just about to go pay an attorney
my wife got up
she called colorado they said what's 60
the guy goes send me a check for a
thousand four hundred dollars and we're
out of this
my wife goes give me your [__]
account number i'll send it right over
that was it
we called california we go you know that
60 we owe you we don't owe you sixty
thousand dollars
why are you doing well late fees
60 000 so you want 58 000 in late fees
guys open your eyes get ready for these
i was like [__] you i'm not paying it my
wife called they said we made a mistake
then it's always a mistake and that's it
i'm out of [__] debt but guys i was
in debt for a long time
so i know it sounds great all these
girls telling you let's get married
we'll put on the visa card [__] you
all that [__] gets paid for cash and
do what you can
but if you go over your head you're
going to be paying that for the rest of
your [__] life because you're never
going to get ahead and if you miss two
payments tell them what happens mike if
you you make those 339 payments you're
done
then you're never getting out of that
[__] hole that's why i can't stand
[__] credit cards i got my american
express back don't ask me how don't ask
me how
and i enjoy my american express first
off there's nothing on it
there's nothing on it and number two but
we pay it every month my wife tells me
she makes me for [__] on it like put
your cvs nicotine i'm like why would i
put something on there and she's like
because i get points i get free plane
tickets and all this [__] so
just take care of yourself guys you know
it's uh
it's a [__] horrible life to live
with bad [__] credit and i did it for
[__] from 90
to 2008 i had bad credit then i got like
an atm card and i got something else and
somebody sent me a card
then i bought a car and that's how we're
here today
and then i ended up with the house so
you know but your credit guys once it
goes bad you're [__] dead so if you
don't i got a friend now i can't do
anything never pay his driving tickets
can't do anything never pay those
driving tickets
and those [__] are unforgiving
never paid his driving tickets from the
time he was you know 20. you know and i
get it yeah like [__] i ain't paying for
this [__] how many times i ripped up a
ticket
until they came to my house to get me
one time and put me in the in the
hallway and underwears with a [__]
band around my arms then i learned to
pay my [__] bills i love you
[__] thank you for a little
podcast we did today just something
simple today like i said there's a
different type of hybrid
it's one day's a zoom which i can tell
you guys don't like neither the [__] do
i
sometimes it's a guest in house
or sometimes it's just me talking [__]
to you [__] i enjoy all three of
them i love doing this [__] i don't know
where i'm gonna be this week uh thursday
night i usually do a set last week
calling let me do a set
i'm gonna try to find somewhere thursday
night i'm gonna go down with jimmy to
the sixth game he's trying to get
tickets as we speak against the miami
heat i haven't been to a [__]
pro game in 30 [__] years so i'm
looking forward to it but besides that i
love you [__] with all my heart
thank you for watching the joint stay
black
and i'll see you [__] monday
morning
tip
top [__] magoo and now for a
word from our sponsors jack
all right i love you [__] i want
to thank you
for supporting the church for having my
back mike's jimmy schubert this week we
had a great week before i leave the
joint is brought to you by green chef
green chef is here to help you eat
better and feel better every week
green chef will send you a new recipe
you get over 30 meal choices every week
and you can switch plans easily
always find a healthy and tasty meal
they got options for every lifestyle
whether you're gluten-free mediterranean
vegetarian vegan cake keto paleo listen
the two-patty dinner that they gave me
they gave me they sent me like two
patties
with truffle aioli unbelievable the
shrimp fried diablo you're gonna light
your hair on fire that's how good it is
green chef is a usda certified
organic company that makes easy and
affordable to eat well you can hand pick
organic veggies so you feel great about
what you're reading and green chef shows
you right up at your door with
everything you need if you're busy like
me and you need to eat healthy
green chef fits perfectly into your
lifestyle now do me a favor go to
greenchef.com
press in
joey 130 and use promo code joey130
because i'm going to get you 130
off
plus free shipping who's better than
uncle joey nobody that's greenchef.com
joey130 and use promo code joey130 green
chef the number one meal kit for eating
well trust me the joint is also brought
to you by cbd lion listen when it comes
to cbd
you're working with the best right here
cbd lion does not play around those
delta nine gummies will put you in
another planet
to cream this kinesiology tape listen
whatever they send you it's gonna help
you but it all starts by you going
to cbd line look at the third party lab
results and look what they could do for
you and how it fits what's going on with
your life that's how good cbd line is so
go to cbd line
get some delta nines maybe try some cbd
cream
pressing co joey a joint and get 20 off
your first order with cbd lion the best
i want to thank
cbd lion
green chef dot com remember slash joey i
want to thank
shelf underpants
and bespoke post they were tremendous
sponsors this week please visit them and
as usual i love you [__] and i'll
see you monday morning tip top
[__] magoo don't tell nobody i
didn't call you love you
[Music]
so
you